a new family attraction is opening on
the las vegas strip you can see it
behind us there it's called flyover
right next to the hard rock cafe this is
full immersion it's a simulated flight
and it picks people up and kind of
showcases them in this spherical screen
images of the wild west technology i
know it's so cool actor mia joining us
live this morning to kind of show us
around hector this is neat
it really is and speaking of technology
the technology is so high tech it has
people in the industry turning heads
that's the screen we were talking about
that right here has a theme and it has
an educational component starting with
prehistoric times and how the
prehistoric times created the real wild
west we live in now joining us live we
have jack general manager here to
explain how the ride works and the
technology that is now here on the las
vegas strip good morning sir
absolutely good morning everybody yes so
the the technology here is you sit in
the ride itself um you put your seatbelt
on we double check the safety is always
first and then this entire pod will
travel out over the dome uh and so the
dome is this large screen and then your
feet are dangling you're ready to apply
jack at first glance it looks pretty
similar to the right over at disney's
california adventure soaring over
california tell us about the
similarities and also is this more high
tech
yeah so soaring is one of the original
flight rides that was that was created
and at that time it had its highest
level of technology that was available
and we've just done the same thing here
we've got the highest level of
technology available so sauron had two
points of axes in its movement of the
pod we have six so the ride is a little
bit more smooth but it also with six
points of axes the creative director and
the film director were able to do more
when they filmed it when the helicopter
because they knew the machine itself
could move in different ways so they
could shoot the film in a much different
way given the new technologies and a
pioneer who worked on soaring over
california worked on this one as well
absolutely yeah rick rothschild is one
of the original imagineers and he worked
for disney for a long time and he was
one of the pioneers of soaring so
he's now on board with us and
he's growing with the technology and
he's excited to uh to take it to the
next level all right let's talk about
hours and staffing we're still in a
pandemic employers right now struggling
to find workers are you guys dealing
with that as well yeah we're absolutely
feeling that i mean we're open from 12
to 8 every day where our operating hours
will expand as we get more staff members
we're looking for team members that want
to come to work and have fun so you're
hiring and touching everyone they are
hiring we are absolutely hiring and and
you know what the attraction that we're
bringing to the people we're bringing
them joy we're bringing them them fun
and excitement and we want to make sure
that our employees have as much fun as
our guests on that note what reaction do
you get from family specifically
children you were like telling me about
your grandson who had so much fun yeah
it's really awesome to watch the kids i
mean it's a completely different
experience for them um it's great to
talk to them afterwards and ask them
what do they remember because it's
certain things that you would never
think like my grandson remembered the
snow and the trees and the train and it
was interesting for me that those are
the things that he picked up on but
those are the things that he doesn't see
every day in las vegas so even being
here those simple things is what really
touched him as far as the flight went so
it's not virtual reality at all it's a
hundred percent real footage mostly shot
from a helicopter absolutely i've shot
from a helicopter there's no virtual at
all
we're sitting in these seats and they're
mesh seats so the mesh seats really make
you feel like you're absolutely flying
not attached to any kind of machinery at
all
and lastly tell us about what was here
before
so here before we took over the united
artist movie theater here and so we took
over three of the large screens that
were here we had to dig down because we
needed our screen to be 52 and a half
feet tall and there wasn't enough space
awesome yeah awesome thank you so much
for your time
we'll be posting all the details on our
website eightnewsnow.com so you can go
ahead and check that out and learn about
the back story about what it took to
place this new right here on the las
vegas strip reporting live hector mejia
eight news now back to you i wanted to
see you up there hector squealing that
was my goal for you
oh i am i was hoping for it but for
logistical reasons kind of have to stay
grounded right now okay fair enough yes
thank you hector appreciate it